what is going on there reject nation we
got ourselves the official volume 2
trailer for stranger things 4. excited
to see what they have in store guys if
you can leave a like please do that
would be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reactions
for volume two start rolling out i think
the first episode of volume two is like
four hours and then the second episode
of volume two is like eight hours so
we're gonna spread out these two
episodes in like part 16s so yeah keep a
lookout for that thank you to athletic
greens for sponsoring this video anywho
let's get to it
[Music]
i know you're framed
you're terribly frightened by what
you've seen
but i'm not gonna lie to you
your friends are not prepared for this
fight so they rescue nancy okay
hawkins will fall
my friends need me
you're not ready
she will be
look at those drums
he's not going to stop
that
it chills man it might not work out for
us this time
[ __ ]
want you to boys
president stevel
more demogorgons
beating up the basketball guy oh
murray
[Applause]
your friends have lost
[Music]
okay so
whatever dimension
that special spot where you know where
max's first goes to in the deer billy
episode it looks like at the very end
there that's where 11 ends up going at
least because you see the door flowers
the creel house there
i can't wait to eat this show up all
over again
i know dude isn't that kate bush this
division of volume one and volume two oh
yes i love it this song is just um oh my
god so popular all over again imagine
that making a song in the 80s and then
cashing in so much money like i heard
they're making like hundreds of
thousands of dollars a week right now oh
yeah sir i think it's kate bush's like
first top 10 hit or something because of
this like years and decades later yeah
it's been huge for for an already
terrific song she planned that in the
very beginning
30 40 years there's gonna be a show
nostalgic for just this time
all right before we talk about a little
bit more a little word from our sponsor
today thank you to athletic greens for
partnering up with us once again no joke
when we first started partnering up with
them i wasn't as familiar with athletic
greens and for the past month in between
that time i had to move and there's been
a whole lot coming out so exercise and
sleep has been very much limited so
definitely needed something to maintain
energy to remain reasonably healthy
we've been having athletic greens every
single day for over a month now about
over a month yeah that's 100 true i feel
like it's made a total difference in my
life i fully attest to it uh ordered
some of our own as well on top of the
ones they already shipped to us so i'm
hoping that we can save partner with
them for as long as possible because i
really do feel like it's been a major
health influence in our lives john why
don't you go ahead and tell them what it
is that we've been taking absolutely
we've been taking their ag-1 formula
which is comprised of 75 high-quality
vitamins minerals superfoods adaptogens
probiotics and more and what's great
about it is it's an all-in-one formula
so it's way cheaper than trying to get
all those things individually and then
come up with some kind of regimen and it
definitely has us feeling sharper
especially on these more sleepless
nights it keeps us feeling relatively
physically clean and fresh as well yeah
sometimes i take it twice a day usually
first thing in the morning right when i
wake up on an empty stomach if i have an
opportunity to work out i'll mix it with
like half of a pre-workout and a lot of
times if i actually have like a bad meal
i will have it at night before i go to
bed and yeah i really do stand by this i
really believe in the product a lot so
yeah no we're not making all the funny
jokes that we usually make because yeah
we are mentally clear and alert right
now thanks to ag-1 in order to make
these claims but also the great thing
too is uh your subscription is less than
three dollars a day for athletic greens
and when you use our special link
athletic greens.com regex you'll receive
some free gifts as well including a
year's supply of vitamin d which uh you
know not everybody gets as much sun as
we do out here in l.a so take advantage
of that for sure so yeah thank you
athletic greens really stand by
everything we just said right now and
happy to be partnering up with you guys
because it's it's been very helpful
thank you this is really interesting
what it seems like vecna is doing with
nancy because you know and this spot in
this trailer looks like he takes nancy
to the events of the rainbow room final
showdown encounter with eleven at least
that's what it appears like in that
moment i'm really curious as to why he's
using nancy so much to show her
everything it's almost as if he's using
her as
like a messenger of sorts she is the
journalist i guess in a way it would
make some kind of thematic sense
although it is kind of funny that he
would be like you are best suited to my
needs everyone coming together seems
like they're all going head on into the
creel house as well you know you got 11
there you got everyone it's pretty much
going head-on we have like an ultimate
game plan of what we're gonna do eddie
grabbing the guitar i love how that's
been teased for so long what exactly is
the master epic plan where eddie gets
the chance to really be something of a
hero and using the instrument he knows
best the extension of himself shredding
to save lives shredding to save some
lives use them sick licks
that's right
all right bro and then somehow this is
all supposed to tie in with uh
whatever's going on with the demogorgons
as well in russia or is that just going
to be something that remains separate
curious to see how that gets brought in
full circle with vecna and all that in
this season and even the basketball i
keep forgetting that basketball player's
name named jason jason right yeah yeah
finally lucas stepping up yes duking it
out with him i'm looking forward to that
i'm looking forward to seeing him get a
little bit of his own uh medicine there
for spiraling off the handle becoming a
radical yeah uh but yeah i mean this
looks so epic and i love that spirit of
like yeah all roads lead back here it
almost feels like we'll probably get
joyce and hopper and murray back with
everybody in season five but that's okay
with the rest of the ensemble like feels
like another era of the 80s with them
the little elements reminding me of like
escape from new york or even things like
red dawn
yeah where you have like characters who
are like a ragtag group of of almost
soldiers and they're all like decked out
and kind of soldier-esque gear and
they're all makeshift armored out and
things like that which also harkens to
dungeons and dragons but i just like the
the kind of breadth of you know film
literacy they're going for in terms of
these 80s esque references and whatnot
that they're continuing with since the
show's beginning little bits of like
resident evil and other stuff in there
look like at the end there that 11 was
blowing up whatever that secret base is
it looks like it yeah which hey maybe
that's the end of the training maybe i'm
done with nina and i'm just gonna bring
it all down but i'm excited for it man
this is awesome this is gonna be a hell
of an experience i can't wait to go
through it but guys what did you think
about the volume 2 official trailer
leave your thoughts down below uh
subscribe click that bell and uh hey
let's do a
mark leach my dude
my dude i need to get back to you you
know what i'm gonna do right now i'm
just gonna reply to you right here and
then i'm also going to reply to you
physically in in text as well on our
patreon so i was like it's been a long
time to hear from mark and you know what
he says to me he says
i said how are you dude everything good
he says yeah i'm okay okay nothing
exciting to tell but getting my
qualifications in child care nice as if
that's not exciting qualifications in
child care helping out the youth is such
an admirable gig that's something super
special to do still drawing other than
that nothing exciting that's pretty
exciting stuff if you ask me man that
you're able to work with children we
don't know enough kind-hearted people
like that
i'm selfish i don't care to help out
kids unless the kids contribute super
chats or pledge to our patreon then i'll
interact with a child rich kid other
than that why would i ever talk to a kid
in fact it might look a little
suspicious see me talking to a kid gonna
be creepy
unless i have a child care background so
you're doing it the right way the smart
way the legal way the healthy way that's
how you become friends with kids that's
how you actually become friends with
kids because there's no other scenario i
can imagine where an adult man is
becoming friends with kids
and that would be disturbing so mark
keep up with not being a disturbing ass
built and helping children and drawing
for them in the right way drawing for
them don't draw them
don't i wouldn't i wouldn't do that raw
though i wouldn't do that that would
might get you in trouble with the child
care you might have to
get fired together
please don't please don't you're going
to do it you're going to get them fired
and best advice answer your other
question haven't seen battle targets and
galactica oh never really been
interested in me neither draw the kids
in battle star please don't do it you're
going to get a major
major artistic trouble with compliments
stop stop here i'm being serious
[Music]